it is another morning on the english
channel for skippers tom and mick
it's looking like somewhere between 20
to 30 people on board this one
just five minutes after leaving the pool
they pass a migrant rescue
and not long after out at sea an empty
dinghy
most mornings when we come down to go
out for our days charter
it's not uncommon to see a you know a
few hundred uh migrants in a day being
processed through the through the
harbour it's pretty shocking stuff
really perhaps they've gone off on a
border force boat or a life boat
who knows
and how often do you see boats like this
all the time
all the while the weather's nice as soon
as it starts to blow then they disappear
you've got the moral obligation of
knowing there's women and children and
people like that floating about who are
desperate
where they can they help bring boats
back to shore they know the pressure
that border forces are under here
yesterday more than 700 migrants are
believed to have arrived
and today we witnessed at least three
groups making it to shore exhausted
a bad plan for us
so
finally we reached here
and how long had you been in in france
for before you crossed
about 15 days
two and a half years ago we were here
reporting when more than 100 migrants
attempted this journey in a month and at
the time that seemed like a really
significant number but now we are
talking about hundreds attempting this
journey in single days and there is a
real frustration here that despite tough
talk from successive home secretaries
things have got so much worse
earlier this year britain agreed a 54
million pound deal with france to more
than double the number of police
patrolling the french beaches now the
home secretary has reportedly said
she'll hold that money back unless a
number of crossings start to fall
the french really need to
up their game
the law at the moment is if you're
undocumented we can't send you back
this is why when they get to the uk
they're so happy this is something we're
going to see for a long long time until
we can agree with the french to stop it
the familiarity of this has made it no
less uncomfortable to see charities want
safer routes opened up the home
secretary wants tougher penalties but
for now hundreds keep coming determined
to make it to britain ali fortescue sky
news doga